Für diese Kinder
ist der Wald ein Spielplatz.
Ein Hang voller Erde
dient als Rutsche,
Messer, Äste und Zweige
als Spielsachen.
Und das Obst am Wegesrand
ist das zweite Frühstück.
Ein Wald nördlich von Berlin:
Hier spielen „Die Waldläufer“,
wie sich der Kindergarten nennt,
jeden Tag, das ganze Jahr.
Sogenannte Waldkindergärten
werden bei deutschen Familien
aus der Stadt immer beliebter.
Ein bis sechs Jahre
sind die Kinder alt.
In diesem Umfeld können sie
sich bestmöglich entfalten,
davon sind ihre Eltern überzeugt.
Ich hab in der Stadt gewohnt und
war dann relativ schnell
an meiner Grenze, sozusagen,
die Kinder dabei zu beobachten,
wenn sie alles vom Boden aufheben.
Es war alles nicht …
also, sie konnten nichts anfassen.
Es war alles irgendwie eklig, dreckig,
Zigarettenkippen, Müll, Hundekacke.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich muss dauernd begrenzen,
und es gibt so wenig natürlichen
Entwicklungsraum irgendwie in der Stadt.
Das Konzept ist recht einfach:
raus ins Freie bei Wind und Wetter.
Einen Stundenplan
für die Kinder gibt es nicht.
Sie sollen spielen und entdecken dürfen,
so wie sie es wollen.
Das ist zwar jetzt sehr spitz,
aber wenn du die Spitze …
Im Moment lernen sie,
mit Werkzeugen umzugehen.
Andreas Apelles ist
seit 14 Jahren Kindergärtner.
Für den Körper und
den Geist eines Kindes
sei nichts besser als die Bewegung
in der Natur, sagt er.
Die Absicht ist,
den Kindern eben ’ne gewisse
Achtsamkeit beizubringen
und dass die Kinder in der Lage sind,
das, was sie hier gelernt haben,
weiterzuvermitteln,
anderen Kindern zu sagen:
Hey, warum trittst du den Käfer tot,
warum haust du die Brennnessel um?
Die Brennnessel ist
wichtig für die Schnecken.
Wenn die Sonne kommt,
können die sich unter den Blättern …,
der Schmetterling legt seine Eier
an der Brennnessel ab.
Oder: Guck mal, die Pflanze
kannst du essen, ja?
Tret [Tritt] sie nicht platt.
So, das ist für uns wichtig.
Ein Tag an der frischen Luft
ist spannend und anstrengend.
Mittags geht es zurück
in das Kindergartenhaus,
Pause in der kleinen Holzhütte.
Daneben steht eine weitere Hütte.
Im Winter wird hier
oft ein Feuer angemacht,
bei Minusgraden bleiben
die Kinder auch häufig drinnen.
Plastikspielsachen sind tabu,
Ablenkung aber ist im Wald
nicht das große Problem.
Manchmal kommen
tierische Gäste vorbei.
Es gibt hier die Schafe vom Nachbarn,
die hier auf dem Grundstück weiden,
und da war der Schafbock dann tot.
Und dann wurde der beerdigt.
Und also, es gibt einfach
so ’ne Wertschätzung für alles.
Auch wenn die Kinder
durchaus explorieren
und die toten Tiere
auseinandernehmen oder so,
aber es gibt trotzdem
einfach so ’n Respekt.
Und ich glaube, dass eben aus diesem
Respekt für Natur, für jedes Lebewesen
auch ein Respekt für andere Menschen,
also für so ’n Miteinandersein,
und auch ’ne andere Verantwortung
für unsere Umwelt so entsteht.
Es ist eine
behütete Kindergartenzeit,
so wie sie viele Kinder
in Deutschland erleben dürfen.
Und wie sie vielen anderen
auf der Welt vorenthalten bleibt.